[Music]
Kevin welcome to the Tim Farriss show
thank you I excited to be here and for
people who don't know Kevin allow me to
introduce Kevin Systrom at Kevin on
Instagram as an entrepreneur and
co-founder of Instagram while at
Instagram Kevin served as the CEO where
he oversaw the company's vision and
strategy and daily operations that is a
whole lot which we will talk about under
his leadership Instagram grew to over 1
billion users that's with ABI and
launched dozens of products including
video live direct messaging creative
tools stories and IG TV the company also
grew to more than 800 employees with a
campus in Menlo Park new offices in New
York City and a new headquarters in San
Francisco prior to founding Instagram
Kevin graduated from Stanford University
with a BS in management science and
engineering he currently lives in San
Francisco with his wife and daughter
where to begin so we've spent a little
bit of time together we have a little
bit of time fortunately not three
minutes on morning television to explore
all sorts of things and I thought we
could start with one since you seem to
read not just why a widely but
intelligently and we'll hopefully get
into that are there any particular books
that you have gifted often to other
people yeah totally on of course now all
my friends are having kids I give kids
books but the one I give people that are
are trying to learn actively as
principals by Ray Dalio
it's interesting actually someone gave
me the PDF it was a PDF before his book
gave me the PDF and I like skimmed over
I was like I was pretty good and they
were like no I seriously think you're
gonna love this and I for some reason I
didn't get around to it for maybe a year
and a half and then I read the actual
book and I was blown away it's both a
guide to life a guide to business and
also I think an insight into Ray and and
someone who's built an amazing business
if you guys listening don't know what he
does he runs a hedge fund called
Bridgewater and he's he's so much more
than you know just a finance thinker
he's also just a brilliant philosopher
so I give that a lot because I think
it's a great guide to life hmm
yeah he's fast
I have I have actually and Ray's been on
the show oh really and for those people
were wondering just just how many commas
are involved in bridgewater capital they
think they have a hundred and sixty
billion dollars under management
something along those lines a little bit
and he has a lot of very in some
respects controversial and unusual
practices within Bridgewater like
recording yeah meetings and so on and
allowing all employees to have access to
the the minutes and so on of such
meetings are there any other books that
helped you in the early days from an
entrepreneurial standpoint or that you
found inspiring totally early on we read
Mike and I both read the Lean Startup I
think is called Lean Startup method or
Lean Startup care remember everybody
Eric Ries and I remember very early on I
was I went to like one of his like book
talks I was like one of like 13 people
sitting in this little room in Palo Alto
and I was like a super fan still am
actually and so I don't know that I've
read the entire thing but the principles
from Lean Startup I still apply today
one of which is like do the simple thing
first and that was our number one value
at a well actually community first was
our number one value at Instagram number
two was do the simple thing first and
still to this day I come back to that so
if I were reading two books I'd probably
read those two books and if we if we if
we look at do the simple thing first
from a practical standpoint could you
give us an example and I love that you
brought up Eric because I remember also
has he also have been on the show he has
not okay but I remember starting he's a
great he's a great guy I would have none
I remember going also to I think some
hotel conference room probably in Palo
Alto when he was initially testing out
the material that later became the book
in these workshops yeah yeah it was like
that yeah talking about avatars and all
sorts of different things doing the
simple thing first the
cope of your responsibilities Instagram
at least reading even just your bio kind
of makes my head spin to imagine what is
involved and how easily distracted you
could become what did what are some
examples or any examples of doing the
simple thing first putting that into
practice yeah the first thing the first
thing I'll say about doing the simple
thing first is people love to make their
lives more difficult than it needs to be
it's like you know you talk to people
who are saving for retirement and you
know you don't have to go figure out a
hedging strategy right like for
currencies to save for retirement turns
out just like generally putting in a
mutual fund is like not a bad idea and
the returns you get for ever more
complex strategies either in life or
finance they're like it's harder to eke
out the incremental value and I think
what I found in a start-up is when
you're small and you're two people it's
me and Mike we're coding late into the
night like you don't have time to make
things complex you have time to make
things work and what ends up happening
is you over optimize so you might think
you know how it's going to break so you
end up trying to build a bunch of things
before it breaks and and then it breaks
in a different way and you're like why
did I spend all that time on you know
that fix when actually I needed to be
doing something else
I feel like that that's true in life I
think it's true in business turned
finance but so some examples
early on I may be the best example at
Instagram was we were here's the
layman's term version we were on one
computer basically one server and we had
enough space to store the data on that
one server and Instagram became popular
right and it turns out all the data
couldn't fit one server anymore and we
were like this is a novel problem let's
figure out how to split it among two
servers or three servers or four and
instead of just like writing a single
file that said like hey listen if your
user ID is you know even you're on this
server and if it's odd you're on that
server which would have charted the data
across two servers very well and
deterministically one ended up happening
was we threw everything out we were like
you know what let's adopt this crazy new
technology that does Auto sharding it
was fancy and had all these bells and
whistles I won't name it because I don't
want to throw them under the bus but we
spent I don't know four months trying to
rewrite our system to be on this new
database and eventually after crashing a
bunch of times and us having issues with
it we were about to run out of space
Mike was like screw it and he literally
spent maybe two hours in the afternoon
writing that file that we should have
written to begin with and it all just
worked so I'm oversimplifying things a
little bit for a fact but like that's
basically what happened and I still
think about that story to this day in
terms of an executive making a decision
with his co-founder about what to do
always do the simple thing first and
it's amazing to me how many people think
the quality of their management they
think is judged based on the complexity
of their decisions or the outcomes and
it turns out actually the right thing to
do is sometimes the simplest and it's
the most effective so I live that as a
value both of life finance and and at
work as well so I'm going to rewind the
clock a little bit please because I
think this ways you could do that in
editing but yes I can and we can slice
and dice but this will be like watching
the movie memento okay I got it
it's basically usually what it's like
when I do an interview yeah exactly
so a pretty pretty standard protocol I
would love to talk about and we won't
spend a ton of time on this because as
we chatted before recording I think
you've talked about the origin story
I've Instagram a lot but for people who
don't have any context I think it's
worth diving into a little bit doing
this simple thing first makes me think
of a common problem that I see in
startups and in software development of
any type really which is feature creep
and these products that start off with a
focus lose focus and it seems to me that
you effectively did the opposite in some
ways for
the creation of Instagram could you give
people a little bit of background on how
Instagram came to be and you can tackle
that short version medium sized however
you like well first of all I'm happy to
talk about where Instagram came from I
just it's such an interesting story in
my life and that I've talked about it a
bunch of times but I forget that it's
actually super interesting to hear for
people who might have signed up for
Instagram a couple years ago think it's
been around forever right
but also I think it has some interesting
lesson so I'll combine both talking
about the storage and storage but also
know how we kept it simple
Instagram came out of one wanting to be
my own boss
I was like you know what I want to work
for myself I want to work on ideas I
really hope I'm gonna make money and I
remember telling at the time my mom I
was like hey I'm gonna go do this thing
and she was like what about health
insurance I was like oh what about
health insurance you're like I totally
forgot so my point is I was a little
naive but I wanted to do my own thing
and I had a bunch of different ideas one
of which was a terrible idea for a check
and app actually wasn't terrible but
like for at the time there were a bunch
of check-in apps and we're sitting in
Austin right now it's South by Southwest
you know zoom back six seven eight years
ago it was all about Gowalla and
Foursquare right everyone was all about
a shirt so I had to have my version and
it wasn't bad but you know it wasn't
good either
and okay so what catchy name yeah it was
called bourbon and bu rbn I still I
think I own the domain name somewhere
but anyway we what what happened I was
working on that I left my job and I
happened to be able to raise money for
it and I'm not sure how or why but
checking apps were all the rage so we
raised some money it was you know a
couple well-known firms in the valley
and I had just enough money to work on
it and I met my co-founder Mike at the
time and I know I needed a bunch of help
because I'm like I'm technical but not
like you know I'm not a true engineer in
the sense like I didn't study it
formally so I met Mike and he was one of
the power users of bar
and he was like yeah this'll be super
fun so we decided to join up we worked
on bourbon for maybe three months and it
was clear it wasn't working
okay it was like very clear the startup
was going nowhere and we decided to
pivot and this is we're keeping it
simple comes in
we actually got to the idea for
Instagram by taking away features from
Bourbon not by changing at all so a
bunch of the features of bourbon one you
could check in at a place but two you
could add a photo of what you were doing
at that place so you and I were out to
drink somewhere I check in at the bar I
could post a photo of the beer I'm
having on the cocktail or whatever right
and it turns out people kind of like the
check-ins the thought was pretty lame
because it was a me-too thing but they
loved showing people what they were
doing they loved taking a picture of the
bar the restaurant that whatever and and
we realized to keep it simple we were
gonna have to cut every other feature of
bourbon which we did and we just kept
the photo part how did you decide on
that feature because we made a list and
we asked ourselves what exists in the
world what sucks
meaning you look out in the world and
you say what opportunity is there to
fill if stuff doesn't exist and it's a
problem that can be solved
aka like the experience sucks then
that's what you should go do there were
a lot of check-in apps there were a lot
of planners and meet up things and group
chat things but there was no solution
for posting great photos to like lots of
friends all at once so we made the list
we crossed off the things we thought
were pretty boring or just there was no
opportunity in them and we circled the
photos thing because we saw the
confluence of both mobile phones being
pervasive like again go back in the day
not everyone had an iPhone like maybe
the iPhone had been out for a couple
years at that point 2078 right so we
knew that cameras were going to be
pervasive in people's pockets that
people are going to be carrying these
camera phones you know wherever they
went but we didn't know if it would be
successful or not to capitalize on that
but it was the only thing
that looked like a greenfield
opportunity everything else felt crowded
that's a different way of saying it so
we got to the idea by cutting everything
away from bourbon circling the one thing
that we felt like was the biggest
opportunity because it didn't exist yet
and it was a big need and we built the
first version of Instagram note by the
way the first version of Instagram did
not have filters and people forget the
only reason Instagram worked early on
was because of the filters and filters
came about because I was on this walk
with my wife we were taking a small
vacation I had been working on bourbon
for a while I was exhausted and we were
taking this walk along on the beach and
I was like oh so you're excited about
this new app we're building we haven't
called it Instagram yet she was like
yeah but I don't think I'm gonna use it
because my photos aren't that good it's
like okay well why don't you think your
photos are good and she's like well all
your friends you know you post these
amazing photos and they're all like
filtered and stuff and I was like oh
that's because they use filters and she
goes oh well you should probably add
filters and we came back from that walk
I went straight to the room and I just
like got on my laptop and I made the
first filter which was ex-pro - this is
a long way of saying we cut features we
focused on what we thought the world
needed and then we got to the heart of
the issue of why people wouldn't use it
because people didn't feel comfortable
sharing their photos by solving those
things right in a row and keeping it
uber simple I mean even that first
filter could have been written in OpenGL
and could have been a lot faster you tap
on that filter it took like three
seconds to show you the filter no one
cared it was fine yeah keep it simple
keep it super simple now you mentioned
you mentioned Eric Ries his book is
perhaps one of the influences I'd like
to look at or dig for lessons learned
best practices observed anything at all
that you took away or very difficult
times anything from a few previous
experiences so we'll go back to the
Mayfield Fellows Program was there
anything in that
that you found particularly useful and
then the next that I'll hit so we could
certainly do them in order or not would
be oh do yeah I mean where do I start
I okay so and what because they feel
solos program yeah Mayfield Fellows
program it's a program at Stanford where
they take I think they still take 12 a
year 12 typically graduate students
although I snuck in on all explain that
in a second who are interested in
entrepreneurship and they they focus on
what is called an entrepreneurship
education so they do three months of
case studies kind of like going to
Harvard Business School but case studies
on just entrepreneurship then three
months you spend at a real startup
getting real experience and then you
come back in the last three months so
it's a year-long program meaning three
quarters of the school year you come
back and you debrief on your own
experience and you actually write
basically a case on your experience over
the summer so I did that I my junior
year I snuck in by like I don't know I
basically I I was like hey but like I
founded this startup not really a
startup it was a website at the time
that was like a competitor to Craigslist
but for Stanford students only and I
prayed that they would take me because I
was so excited about entrepreneurship
and they let me in years later by the
way one of the people who ran the
program still runs the program actually
pulled me aside and was like just so you
know we were barely about to let you in
I was like thank God you did and she was
like but the thing that made the
difference was that you were out there
actually trying to start something and I
guess lesson number one is like never
expect you're gonna get a no like always
put your name in write number two is
actually do the thing like actually
start the start of it don't just go to
conferences about it don't just like
write articles about started do
something and that carries a lot of
weight um but that was the Mayfield
Fellows program and maybe the last
lesson on the Mayfield Fellows program
that I I got from it was really there's
nothing in the
all that can substitute for real
experience doesn't matter what we're
talking about if you want to be a chef
working in a kitchen is the only way
you're gonna learn going into culinary
school whatever I'm sure is great but
working in a kitchen is the way to do it
if you want to be gosh
like a like a tech founder right you got
a star to start up you got to know what
it feels like to put it all on the line
lose everything and then come back right
you can't learn about investing unless
you invest I mean name whatever
profession it's like real experience is
so much better than what's in a book
that doesn't mean the books aren't
helpful but you got to do it but they're
an adjunct yeah yeah very hard to become
a professional soccer player by reading
books on the physics of soccer although
I got to tell you I took this
personality test and the results came
back but one of the main takeaways was
like prefers learning by reading and I
was reading my results to my family
because I thought I would be
entertaining and my mom was like oh my
god like I remember when you were a kid
you just read everything and my dad was
like yeah like you said you were gonna
be interested in playing baseball so I
was like I bought a mitt for you and we
were gonna go play catch and you're like
dad I got to go to the library and I my
dad was like what he's like I got a read
about it so I literally went to the
library I read about how to pitch and
then played and I think that's my mo
it's just I'm wired that way do you
remember the there was an okay page the
name of the personality test or the
assessment they didn't yes it was the
golden personality tests golden
personality yes I think it was golden
yeah mm-hmm why did you take that test
it's a it's a variant on the
myers-briggs test but it actually gives
you very specific breakdowns of every
dimension so for those of you listening
that don't know the myers-briggs test
there are basically four main dimensions
of the personality test and tells you
for instance whether you're more casual
or if you're like very calculated and
punctual that kind of stuff I wanted to
know more about what I was like i talked
about Ray Dalio before I spoke with him
and he was saying yeah everyone who
joins Bridgewater we give this
personality test I was like well can I
take it like I want to know what I am
and my co-founder took it a bunch of our
senior execs took it and it was
illuminating to learn see on paper which
you know in the back of your mind and
then of course it helps you work with
others but a big part of it was reading
on paper what you're actually like and
realizing for instance I do learn by
reading so I'm not someone who likes to
sit in a lecture hall I want to have the
book so if I'm gonna learn something new
like the way to learn is not for me to
go to like a conference it's to like sit
down with the best book possible and
that might not apply to you right like
if you took it maybe you like learning
some other way but I wanted to know what
my API was so that was helpful your API
yeah I like it that's true yeah we all
are an application programming interface
all right Houston is some acronyms on
reading there are different ways to read
books and I had found in some of the
research for this conversation a mention
of Mortimer Adler's how to read a book
yeah could you talk about how you read
how weird is it that I'm like so into
reading that I have to find a book
that's how to read like where does it
stop how to read how to read a book okay
have you ever read the book I haven't
okay it's fine I can save you some time
yeah basically the idea behind this book
is its how to read a book most
effectively most people open the first
page and they start with the first word
and then they go until either that they
get bored or they push through or
whatever and the claim in the book is
basically that that is not correct that
instead what you should do is
familiarize yourself with the structure
of the book first so the most important
I say
his thesis the the mo is that the most
important part of reading a book is to
actually read the table of contents and
familiarize yourself with like the major
structure of the book and then
familiarize yourself by skimming the
book and figure out what the main
arguments are in fact that one of the
secrets that I love and I can still do
to this day is most authors
in the last paragraph of every chapter
especially the last paragraph of the
book will not only summarize their main
arguments but make the points they
actually have been waiting to make the
entire chapter and by reading just those
paragraphs you get a pretty good idea of
what the books about then you go back
and you read like you normally read but
with the context of knowing the overall
arc of the story rather than guessing
where it's gonna go I don't recommend
doing this with a thriller because
you'll ruin your experience but with
nonfiction I think it's fantastic
but that's that's how to read a book and
by the way for those of you Mortimer
fans out there I probably didn't do it
justice but go by the block yeah go by
the book which will encourage you to buy
yet more books I have this seriously if
I could show you my room right now my
bedside table is just stacked with books
I've got a book called mathematics
politics because I'm interested in both
politics and also the math behind
elections and that stuff I think how to
read a book is probably there one of the
books do I have I've got books on on
flying because I'm learning to be a
pilot it like it ranges oh I've got a
quantitative finance books I've got but
like it's the most fun I've ever had
just like plowing through books I guess
it's good I don't know the job right now
I don't know it does create a little
space okay cries how quickly it gets
filled out it does well I mean you're
not I don't think is it yeah especially
the long ones no it's okay oh do mm-hmm
what was oh do and and what did you
learn there what did you observe yeah oh
do is the precursor to Twitter so you we
were talking about Mayfield Fellows
Program my internship was oh do so that
three months over the summer I spent at
oh do I remember I showed up the first
day I brought my own computer because I
thought when you worked at a comedy you
bring your own computer because I was
like I don't computers are expensive
right like you bring your own and
they're like oh good you brought your
own computer I think they were thrilled
and it was Evan Williams and and no
glassware the cofounders of oh do and
they're like oh I forgot you started
today and I was like yep Here I am and
actually it was one of the best
experiences learning from EV who's
brilliant and Noah who's also brilliant
and like just seeing that startup tried
to take off it was a podcast directory
believe it or not maybe a little early
yeah it was the right way but they just
Pat a literally yeah which by the way
another lesson and this whole thing
timing is everything like the number of
amazing ideas and teams that either came
too early or too late it's like you got
to have that essential element of timing
and it's the hardest to predict but it
was a podcast directory and you know
honestly a lot of the the famous podcast
folks got started on audio and there are
a bunch that are still around but turns
out back then there wasn't exactly a
business around podcasts and it didn't
go so well
and they ended up pivoting to an idea
started by an engineer there Jack Dorsey
who by the way also started I think like
maybe my first or second day and I
remember him walking in and I'm like on
the intern he's like oh I'm Jack and I
learned actually he gave me a couple of
coding assignments over the summer I
remember learning some JavaScript from
him so it's a small world it turns out
yeah super small but that's what Odia
was and that was my experience it was
awesome and I'm very thankful to all
those guys what do you view as some of
say just as an example of superpowers
you know he's very impressive guy very
understated in a lot of ways what did
you what did you observe in the secret
sauce of of F because he's also a repeat
player right I'm in this yeah he's not a
one-hit wonder
yeah so what what have you observed in
him turns out blogging and communication
is a thing and doesn't go away and there
are lots of companies that can be
started around it what did I observe was
a really long time ago but or what
superpowers do you think yes you could
talk present tense to so I think he's
super determined and super calm under
fire
there are a lot of there are a lot of
CEOs that are very like emotionally
volatile and at least in my experience
is not one of those people
in fact he's determined and hardworking
and I can't remember his background
story but he's like yeah you know I went
to this college it wasn't that great and
I just worked my ass off to get here and
to build this thing and then eventually
sell it to Google that was blogger
and then to be able to start this thing
and I remember his work ethic because at
one point I'm pretty sure he was
convinced we all weren't working hard
enough so he sent us he didn't send us
he offered for us to go to this seminar
by David Allen the getting things done
things done so I remember sitting in the
audience and just like the OTO crew they
were like I don't know six or seven of
us at the time at the David Allen
getting things done you know NOC
conference but seminar I still try to
use that stuff today by the way
but the signal was like we work hard
here and we get stuff done and he was
there you know he was the first one in
last one out and as a CEO I understood
what that model meant one that I could
learn from the CEO that if they had ways
of getting things done you could you can
learn that as an employee and I tried
very hard at Instagram to learn stuff
and then pass it on but also just the
work ethic that is required to get
startups off the ground
it's incredible plus willing to call it
like he was willing to call OTO and
pivot to this thing called Twitter and
trust me when we were calling it on
Bourbon and pivoting to Instagram I was
thinking about that moment I wasn't
there in the room when they did it but I
can imagine you know the the bravery
that it takes to switch like that it's
hard but uh but paying attention to
people like eV and entrepreneurs like
that and entrepreneurs like Jack I think
you begin to learn that there are
patterns and you have a little faith in
their ways and and you you end up trying
to mirror it in many ways
I completely agree on the the ev having
calmness as a competitive advantage he's
very good
pausing and not jumping to respond so
he's better able to choose his response
I suppose instead of being reactive I
think you're very good at that as well
Thanks and I want to talk about since
its come up a few times pivoting or
ending projects yeah because there's a
in some aspects a fetishizing of
perseverance in a lot of places
including Silicon Valley and the world
of tech and yet if you if you look at a
lot of the largest public successes many
of them had some type of pivot or
shutting down of something that wasn't
working how do you know it's the right
time to stop and when how does one go
about making that difficult decision
like are there telltale signs that this
is just it's not that another 50% of
effort is required another X number of
hours per day but like this is
fundamentally flawed in some way that is
gonna prevent it from working I think
let's take this question in two parts
first is let's just talk about the
premise that most successful things are
pivots which I believe is true one of
the really fun things to do is actually
do you know the Wayback Machine I -
right I think it still exists I haven't
tried in a long time but you can go and
type in it any wet web address and then
I think it allows you to like select the
date of that website so you can
basically see the history of the web
it's super interesting go to YouTube and
figure out when YouTube was founded I
can't remember but like you can look it
up on Wikipedia right and go to that
date like around the beginning you will
see YouTube was a dating site before it
became YouTube what we know as YouTube
right do that for most major things that
you get excited about or like look up
the history of Facebook when it was you
know it was Facemash before and it was
something before that the only one that
I don't think was a pivot was Google and
they've done pretty well so that's the
one counterexample like that literally
was their project and they made it a
company and it worked really well so I
don't know
but most other projects are our pivots
from an original idea and I think that's
because one it's really hard to tell
what works a priori like doing it before
anything before you actually you know
put it into into people's hands it's
really difficult like you don't know if
it's gonna work
the key to entrepreneurship is failing
really quickly so putting it out there
seeing if it works if it doesn't then
diagnosing why and then like focusing on
how to improve it from there so one I
agree with the premise that most things
are in fact like second runs and then to
the importance of pivot I think is that
most of the time you get it wrong so the
question is knowing you're gonna get it
wrong how equipped are you to deal with
that failure really quickly before you
run out of money and the entrepreneurs
that I've seen do very well are the ones
that are equipped and engaged on the
change from something that's not working
to something that is far too many people
because of ego or whatever stick with
idea is far too long and I think you
know it ends up really poorly
yeah or look at something it isn't
working that might have a different
application right if you look at post-it
notes I'm actually a failed adhesive
right yeah and then you look at say
viagra which was failed it was a a
failure from the perspective of whatever
it was initially tested for or intended
for which I think was lowering blood
pressure and normalizing blood pressure
and then the they're like excuse me can
you check off all the side effects of
this blood pressure pill the the like ah
there's a pattern here
well the the recipients were asked to
send back their samples and all the
women sent their samples back and almost
none of them Endon they're like wait a
second what's going on here I can't tell
if this is a family friendly show and we
should dive into this or we get weakened
uh you know it is family friendly but
modern family used to be the director
Scott this will be the director's cut
this is like anyway pivots are important
pivots are important and how do you
train if you do the
to recognize say confirmation bias or
this is something certainly ray thinks a
lot about is identifying from the
perspective of an investor where you
might have be succumbing to some cost
fallacy or any of these other things
that could steer you to make bad
decisions or or not stop things heads is
that something that you've you've
trained in yourself or is that innate
from birth or upbringing I think I was
talking with my wife the other day and I
was like Nicole I think one of my
failures is that like I always think
things are not gonna work out or I'm
wrong in some way and and we were going
back and forth I was she was like oh
well maybe that's actually a strength
because like you're so hard on an idea
that you're like trying to prove
yourself wrong to test the integrity of
your idea or test the integrity of your
thesis or and like so you mentioned Ray
like I think a big part of knowing that
you're right is working as hard as you
can
to prove that you're wrong and if you
can't well there's only one option left
which is you're probably right
but a lot of people I think are afraid
to gather feedback well I think Mike and
I and Instagram very early on tried our
best to be open to feedback I think as a
young executive I was like no on the
boss like all ideas are great all my
ideas are great right and after a couple
failures I think you learn really
quickly that like hey listen I know
there's this myth that like the best
founders just have like the Midas touch
and every idea they have is perfect you
know like Steve Jobs he touches
everything and it just becomes gold and
it's right but it turns out there are a
lot of failures in these people's lives
they just usually get written out of
history and then what you see is as a
trail of amazing ideas I mean someone
should write a book on all the bad ideas
amazing people have had right over the
years and just ten volumes said totally
but like I think people get the wrong
idea there is no
Midas touch like that one of the things
I hated most working in tech was the
idea that there's like a product guy our
product girl right like that you're like
somehow someone who just knows what's
gonna work
most the successful people I know have
tons of bad ideas and it's about editing
them out and figuring out which one is
actually right because honestly what is
the Mendoza line it's like if you bat
200 like above 200 you're like a pretty
good batter right like in a world where
your average is gonna be 1% you got to
generate a ton of ideas before you get
one roughly 100 right yeah so and 1%
would be like way higher than the
average so how do you figure out which
is the one it's I think it's by being
super not mean to yourself a critical on
the idea in a in a constructive way and
pressure testing it with other people
but I just I like always have I don't
know I'm just wired in a way that
assumes every whether it's idea or
thesis or whatever I have is wrong and
I'm I'm more worried about being wrong
than I am looking bad you don't I mean
no I get it
do you have any particular questions
that you ask yourself or other people on
your stress testing an idea or
alternatively how you solicit feedback
and I give an example since I write I
have all these books I want people to
act as proof readers but I don't want
them since they are my friends to be
unnecessarily nice because what the
whole white yeah and so I one of the
questions on my is in a given chapter
I'll say if you had to cut 10 to 20%
yeah gun to the head which 10 to 20
would go nice right and it forces their
hand in a that's smart so are there
other approaches that you like to use or
like others to use on your ideas for
stress testing well first off I think
it's important to realize how people are
just wired not to be honest not that
they lie I mean I guess technically
Alai but i don't think it like comes
from a bad place they're wired to avoid
conflict so like you go in a restaurant
and the server comes by you know maybe
you didn't like a dish the server comes
by when's the last time you actually
literally told them like everything was
great but that thing was too salty that
was you know I like to eat by the way
that thing was too salty that was
undercooked like next time you go out to
eat and they're like how is everything
and you're like you instinctively just
respond great thanks if it is that
actually what you thought like most
people have one or two things they wish
could be better and what's crazy is I
think of myself in that situation every
time I was sitting down there I'm like
men if I were on the other side of this
I'd really want to know the truth
because without the truth you can't
improve right and you have to be careful
because sometimes people have opinions
and they're not always right but if you
don't know you can't act on it and I've
been surprised how many people I've met
at least in the food industry right
where at least if you do it in a nice
way
you're like listen I just if I were on
the receiving end of this I'd want to
know so I'm giving this to you do
whatever you want with it and it's
always interesting to see the people
that are like grateful for that feedback
and you're like that person's gonna go
kick some ass totally and the people who
are like what's supposed to be that way
you know and you're like well okay like
but like what if it isn't and I think
it's really important as you mature as
an executive like I definitely start in
the place where I just like didn't
listen to feedback I was you know
headstrong and then as you have more and
more failures that by the way everyone
has you begin to realize it's really
important to collect that data and that
information from people no one would
tell me like when I was presenting on
stage everyone would be like great ah
great awesome job
great you killed it there's like that's
not possible like like a few talks in a
row that happened and then we hired
someone and I'm not gonna pick on them
and tell you who they are but we hired
someone who came up to me after and gave
me three pieces of feedback
like you need to smile more you need to
do that like I know you're a happy
person but you're not smiling when
you're talking about this really happy
subject like smile and I was like oh my
god that person's right they literally
watched every single interview I had
done for like the last two years and
just had a list of things and I was so
grateful for that because it was
feedback that no one else would give me
do you remember any of the other points
it was slowed down pause right
it was smile more not because you're
trying to give off a vibe that but just
what's funny is you can't overdo smiling
it turns out like it's hard and I'm just
like I'm a serious person so I don't
think smile as much
what were the other things I'd have to
go back to my notes but those are the
two things that stood out yeah it's
people don't give you feedback it's
crazy and by the way the whole thing is
the more important your company gets the
higher up you go the less people are
willing to do it yeah so you actually
have to like dig for it and that's one
of the weirdest feelings ever is please
tell me something negative but you asked
a specific question which is like what
are the tools to do it I don't know that
they're any like specific tools so much
is like when's the last time you the
listener did that when's the last time
you went out of your way and you said
hey like I really want honest feedback
on this and when someone gives you
feedback you don't respond in a
defensive way you say thank you and you
encourage the behavior if you could do
that man like the self-improvement that
comes with that you know and the honesty
that comes with it if depending on the
format can be really remarkable I you
may have done this before but I had not
done a 360 interview oh yeah I avoided
doing the first one they wanted me to do
ever it was like hah this is just like a
management thing and then the second one
I did I literally tried like hard to do
it like I asked people to participate I
said please be as honest as possible
yeah and I remember setting with Joe
Gebbia about his first 360 interview and
for people who do not know what that is
there are different ways to approach it
but in effect your superiors peers /
colleagues and subordinates are all
interviewed so the people you into
with most are all interviewed about your
strengths and weaknesses and so on and
very frequently at least in my case with
my employees and so on
it was anonymized to ratchet up the like
allowable honesty and it was a great
example of how valuable honesty can be
and also how difficult it can be to
digest if it's really full frontal yeah
and i think joe said 'i like windows car
in the park like Heidecker words I had a
tough time I had a really tough time
with it but it ended up being very
helpful when I was able to look at it
with a cooler head not because I was
angry but I was really sort of like cut
down at the knees by some of the
comments and it was really important I
mean if you have spinach stuck in your
teeth you need somebody to tell you I
think the hardest part is how to tell
when you've got spinach stuck in your
teeth or someone just doesn't like you
and but you have to be willing to get
both yeah and then ask yourself which of
these have merit and not to write things
off but you have to be able to go
through it and just ask yourself but
yeah that was hard yeah I remember my
first one and I just but now I think
about it and like no matter what I do
whether it's another company whether I'm
doing a writing project or a podcast
whatever like so I just walked off the
stage at South by Southwest and I could
see the screen that was displayed after
we left and they asked people to rate
the rate everything like rate the
speakers or at the host like and I was
like oh I really want that data I'm
gonna ask him for it
because I want to know like was it
interesting to people what topics didn't
they like like did we come off as
authentic inauthentic like where were we
on but it's funny because no one ever
tells you anything
James it's unless you dig for it you
won't find it but honestly I think
letting people know that it's safe to
give feedback asking for it proactively
etc etc is important I just the amount
people go out of their way to avoid
conflict is pretty wild
yeah which which often works in the
short term but can
be caustic and erode relationships in
the long term and if you're avoiding
that and your comment on the rating on
screen made me think of Kyle Maynard who
is an incredible incredible guy is I was
also been on the podcast but he had
learned at one point or was given a
piece of advice from very successful CEO
of a large company that if you ever
asked somebody to write something from
one to tend to disallow 7 because 7 is
this like semi pipe is all
three-and-a-half stars you're like yeah
no exactly so you're mentioning
restaurants so and I'll very often ask
people in restaurants if they're giving
me the everything is good response which
is gives me no information to act on as
I'll say all right on any I'll give them
two options and I'll say 1 to 10 but no
7 how do you rank and it's it's sort of
bared then they're they're forced if
they're struggling that to do a barely
passed which is a six I'm not gonna
order that or an 8 which is strong
that's a that's a confident endorsement
and so that can be applied to all manner
of things that's really cool
let's do that from now on you know
sevens let's let's talk about tough
times because you mentioned there are
none the life of an entrepreneur is old
and true it's you know it's it has been
it has been said that your life is all
highlights no I'm kidding that hasn't
been said company made that happen I
wanted to I want to talk about I want to
talk about some of the may be tougher
times that that you willing to share if
any some of the maybe of course darker
periods tough decisions were any time
you had kind of self-doubt or felt lost
because and where I'm going with this
I'm very curious how you then
recontextualized it found the silver
lining I just got through it because
it's some people get knocked down and
they have a really tough time getting
back up so when people are able to do
that I like to look look inside and see
what actually happened yeah so yeah any
any at all that you're willing to talk
about first thing I'll say is a lot of
people
assume that like businesspeople
entrepreneurs like whether they make
money like a lot of money or they sell a
company or they go public or whatever
and they're SEOs for a long time or
world leaders whatever a lot of people
assume these people don't struggle right
that somehow they're inhuman or whatever
like I I feel like I wake up every day
with a lot of the same worries I did
before Instagram was a thing am i
working on the right thing did I do
enough today is that idea the right idea
and I still have just as many failures
as I did before Instagram and well
inside of Instagram as well now don't
get me wrong there are structures around
me now that allow me to like come back
from those failures but I guess my point
is like getting knocked down is like a
really common thing no matter where you
are in your career no matter where you
are in your progress of building
something and in fact it usually happens
more the more important thing you're
doing right so early on at Instagram I
think there were a bunch of times I
remember pitching the idea and having
really smart intelligent folks look at
me like I was a crazy person for working
on anything related to photos I remember
trying to hire some of like the most
amazing designers early on who just like
wouldn't join because they didn't
believe in the app I remember press
stories or investors investing in
competitors even though they had
invested in us so choosing the other
which is fine listen like it's up to
like investors should be able to choose
who they think the winner is that's
their job but it's tough right to think
you're not the winner all of these
things happened along the way and we
were knocked down multiple times whether
that was in our heads or actually there
in reality but the thing that kept us
going was realizing it wasn't other
people we were trying to impress I mean
of course we wanted a community for the
app the reason we got backup each and
every time was because we loved what we
were doing right like if your goal is to
gain people's approve
like the startup business is a terrible
business to get into
heck like if you're a singer like it's
the worst business to be in in the world
because everyone's gonna tell you your
stuff stinks until maybe a dozen right
but you have to believe in what you're
doing and love what you're doing that
itself has to bring you the most amount
of excitement otherwise getting knocked
down is gonna knock you off the horse
and you're all forever and I often think
like was it determination that got us to
where we got or luck or some combination
of both of them because I don't know if
you have a bad idea and you're
determined on it and don't listen to
anyone it's like not great right yeah
but at the same time we wouldn't be
where we are if I had listened to most
people it's crazy yeah
so I don't know if there's a secret to
getting back up otherwise other than
maybe creating no choice but to get back
up like I didn't have another job what
was I gonna do like sign up for business
school I don't know like I had quit my
job and raised a bunch of money and I
really loved what I was doing so every
time one of these failures would occur
what was the other option can you think
of one desk job a desk job can you think
of an example of a tough time a tough
decision a tough rejection from an
investor a designer anything and what
you then said to yourself I'm very
curious about self-talk right so it's
like whether it's like Shaun White on
the final run in the Olympics and I
asked him what he said before he left
the gate to himself and it was who cares
and he like explained why it's like who
cares and I didn't expect that answer
and I found it really interesting I mean
in the sense that like he's done all the
preparation he could possibly do he's
either ready or he isn't
and there was an entire explanation for
it
and what fighters say before they get in
the ring if there is some type of
self-talk I got one yeah yeah let's go
straight to the interesting topic
selling our company yeah so we sold our
company and it was April of 2012
and by all accounts if you start a
company for a lot of entrepreneurs
winning quote-unquote and by the way I
don't agree with this definition but but
winning is quote unquote either selling
your company or you know having a public
offering an IPO for a lot of people
that's like the traditional outcome for
a start-up and we had sold and we were
13 people and it was a billion dollars
it was really exciting and and I
remember like right afterwards everyone
being like so it's over and I feel like
that was the most painful thing to hear
because I had no intention on you know
not doing Instagram I like wanted to
work on it for the next you know
whatever years but everyone I met was
like so you're done now so it's over I
was like no no no no and like we would
try to hire people and they'd be like no
it's over and I remember people working
at the company telling me it was over
and a couple of people ended up leaving
pretty soon after that and I remember
one of them saying yeah there's like
nothing else to learn here like work we
go from here
mind you at the time we had about 50
million users we got to a billion by the
way we had no revenue we got to a lot
more than no revenue we grew to a
thousand people on the team
we opened up multiple offices all around
the world I got to do everything we're
meeting the Pope to meeting some idols
like I got it was crazy so the idea that
in 2012 we sold our company and then
everyone just kind of counted us out
that was painful what how did you
contend with it like what was your
response to that I think with me it
usually comes with the competitive
nature of proving people wrong if you
look at that like histogram sorry to use
that word but of how long founders stay
after they saw their company I'm pretty
sure there's like a giant like lump
around one month to one year right
we were there for six years after we
sold which I think goes to show how
incredibly determined we were to show
people that Instagram wasn't done that
we were at the beginning not the end and
that it didn't matter if we sold the
company we were gonna make something out
of this thing and for me I think the
motivation comes with proving people
wrong because I hate when people
discount us I hate when people you know
tell us we're not gonna be something we
weren't you know that because we've sold
it's all over
but looking from the outside I get their
perspective I just wanted to prove them
wrong yeah yeah it's not all motivator
yeah
I think and part of taking that
personality test we talked about is
understanding what your motivators are
because if you know what your motivators
are then you know how to get yourself up
in the morning how to work hard had it
right and you know what things are not
motivating but competition is one
actually it's interesting there were two
dimensions of the personality test there
was competition and then there's
challenge and I didn't I always thought
I was competitive it turns out I'm
actually not competitive at all I mean
I'm a little competitive but not that
competitive I have very high scores on
challenge which means setting goals for
yourself and trying to meet them but
it's like self-imposed rather than
comparative right in sort of an
intrinsic yeah motivator it's an
internal motivator of like I want to go
get this thing done so for me I think at
that moment it was more about self
challenged to prove to myself that I
could do it and that we could build this
thing
it worked how did you learn to manage
that's that's a man and I had to yes how
does one learn to manage because you and
it's not just time within a larger
company right because you can you can
find plenty of people who make the same
mistakes for 20 years in a row yeah and
somehow managed to limp along and sort
of do decently despite their weaknesses
but when you sold
the company how many employees do you
1313 yeah that's I think I manage like
three of them right so so that you then
went through why do you think companies
of hierarchy they're like I don't want
to manage people you manage them and
before you know it you've got like a
tree you know 90 layers deep I'm joking
well I be I don't mean there is some
truth to that I think but how did you
learn a manager were there any
particular lessons resources so I have
to say anything at all well I was gonna
say my job was different than most which
obviously is an understatement but like
I'm gonna tell you the philosophy I
subscribe to you and then I think you're
the listeners can decide if it makes
sense for them it might I decided that I
had nothing to lose because at least I
didn't think I had anything to lose
because I had my job I was excited about
it I was running this thing and I knew
what I didn't know or at least knew that
I didn't know a bunch of stuff my
philosophy was hiring the smartest
possible people were way better than me
to work for me and that feels weird
because you're like I have no experience
I've been doing this for two years how
do I hire someone that has maybe 15
years of experience in engineering or 15
in you know operations or the list goes
on but the ironic thing is by hiring
people that were way better than me but
like I would see myself working for some
day if they started a company that
actually you end up creating the best
possible team and I think that works
because I felt like I had job security
so a lot of people are worried well if I
hire great people beneath me then then
maybe one of them will take my job and I
don't know where like the reality is on
that spectrum in the real world like I
don't know but I think that's actually
one of the issues I looked for most in
the company which was people hiring down
on purpose like people do it reflexively
they hire down they're like no I need
someone with less experience than
they should be younger they should have
let fewer years of experience right
because I should coach them and actually
if everyone hired up you'd have like the
most badass company in the world so how
do you manage that that I guess my point
is I found people that were way better
than me and the way I managed was by
managing the vision and direction of the
company and then asking those people how
to get there and making sure those two
things were connected at all times but I
didn't have the regular job of like you
know managing a bunch of new grads out
of college and like coaching them on
their careers which exists in mass in
Silicon Valley so I'm not sure my
management like experience mirrored that
of most but I think there's a lot to
learn which is hire really great people
that someday you want to have you know
they should have your job so you hire
these people if you subscribe to this
philosophy and then I imagine there are
different strategies and routines and
rules and so on they put in place to
give structure and direction to this
team of all-stars and so so one that I
can ask about it would be meeting
structure so in the course of prepping
for this and I found this a few places
but in the New York Times feel free to
fact-check this but I'll just read this
briefly and then we can I'd love to hear
you elaborate on what the meeting
actually looks like and and how you
handle it so some of the bottlenecks
this is from the air time some of the
bottlenecks the company's addressed in
the last in the past year are internal
for example mister system and his
co-founder realized that one of the
primary holdups was their own
decision-making so in the past three
months they started holding meetings in
which they just make a bunch of
decisions and then this is quoting
mister sistrum we have a dock in which
we list out the inventory of decisions
on products as if it's stacked up in
front of the machine waiting to be
processed mister sistrum said and then
we have sessions where we sit down we
decide you just work through the
decisions so so this is something that
you might be able to do in an informal
unbanned you have three direct reports
or 13 employees but as a
Rose it seems like this type of
systematizing could be really important
could you describe how a meeting like
this functioned totally and whines it's
really funny for me to think of myself
as being referenced as mr. sister it's
very it's very formal mr. system with
inventory of decisions okay so here's
the context have you ever read the book
the goal the goal the goal I have not
yeah
it is a book about basically
manufacturing and supply chain
management
it sounds really boring but I promise
you it's really good last name is gold
rat I think it's gold rat yeah who wrote
the book and it's kind of and in fact if
you talk to business people a lot of
people will say it's their favorite book
like I wrote and one of my weekly
updates to the team I wrote that I was
reading this book and that I loved it
and a bunch of people were like oh I
love that book too so it's a business
book that talks about how to optimize
supply chains basically but it's written
in narrative form which is kind of
cheeky right yeah it's a it's not like a
business it's a business book but it's
like written with a narrative like there
are characters and and it's actually
pretty fun so I say go have a read but
what I realized in reading this was that
any system is most constrained or at
least the thesis of the book is most
constrained by the slowest process I
think they called it a Herbie Herbie
have you ever heard that I have yes it's
because the beginning of the book kind
of like always Scouts yeah exactly if
you want to explain I know we're getting
there how many times our Boy Scouts
gonna come up in a podcast right so the
narrative is that they're on some trip
and they like have these Boy Scouts
lined up I think it's like you know the
main characters son or something is in
the line of Boy Scouts and an Herbie it
might not be PC to talk about now but
Irby is a little overweight and he's at
I see at the back I don't
basically they figure I think it the way
it goes is no matter where they put him
in the line the line can only move as
fast as the slowest process that's kind
of the take away okay again people who
are superfans the goal can correct me on
this but the essence of it is your
slowest your slowest part in the chain
is always going to limit output in this
case the slowest boyscout limits the
progress the troop makes which isn't
actually all that isn't all that
intuitive until you read this book and
you go through it so with
decision-making what we realize is a lot
of things we're coming to us but unless
we would decide on an important decision
it was basically like inventory stacking
up in front of a machine that wasn't
moving and of course the machine can
output products that people want to go
use until those decisions get made
so it sounds again really intuitive but
if you think about a company as you know
if the raw materials go in and raw
materials are ideas okay and they go
through machines that transform them
into reality so they go from an idea to
a mock to a you know a final a final
draft to a version to out testing with
beta testers out to the real world that
actually what you need to do is make
sure all machines are running at highest
capacity including the one that moves
ideas from the idea pile to mocks from
mocks to actual right so you work down
the chain and we realized very early on
in reading this book that a lot of the
lessons that usually apply to
manufacturing actually apply to making
decisions at a company as well I had
actually forgotten about that book until
you mentioned it I'll have to pick it up
yeah the goal have a long list of books
to tackle how do you choose books that
you're going to read I know you given a
few examples of things that you're
interested in but how do you filter the
universe of books to those who end up
reading and I mean you can maybe just
pull up you could pull a few real
examples from from
those you've read and it can indicate
how you got to those but is do you have
a process for selecting books
well first or describe well first I
don't read fiction not that there's
anything wrong with fiction and I know
people that read a lot will be like what
you don't read fiction come on there's
so many greats I don't know it just
doesn't get me up in the morning so
there we go there goes you know a good
portion of books down to non fiction
non-fiction books then I asked myself
what topics I care deeply about or what
things I really want to learn so for
instance learning to fly like okay what
are the best books to learn to fly or if
I want to learn about investing or
finance what are the best books or if I
want to learn about productivity what
are the best books and obviously Amazon
is great for that and you can read
through reviews and but honestly a big
part of me reading is just like there's
usually some outcome I want like I want
to be able to do X what do I have to
read that will teach me as fast as
possible because like with a book okay
so with a class you gotta like wait
until the class happens go to a class
and then wait until the next class with
a book you can literally like just get
through it in a week or a day or and
then you can reread it and then reread
it and I just I find that like if you
want to learn a new skill there's
nothing like sitting down with a
nonfiction book on that topic that's you
know well laid out and but sometimes you
know you gotta call it I've been a
quarter way through a bunch of books on
topics that I thought I was gonna like
and just thrown them out cuz I think
these are trash so they don't it doesn't
always work that way
do you read and if you don't this isn't
a value judgement biographies do you
ever read biographies okay so I have not
read no but I really want you okay so
the one area that I want to spend way
more time on this history including
biographies which I consider a form of
history although biographies can be
fairly selective in the history they
tell that's true of all history books I
feel like they're how are you
41 pretty sure that's okay well factory
I'll get back to I'm 35
okay our lives are really short compared
to the history recorded history and it
turns out if you look back in history
things patterns emerge I read this great
book called lessons of history
it's just have you read it will an
aerial address yeah it has it's short
it's excellent it's like a leaflet like
you could read it in a day it's great
there's some parts that I disagree with
but for that I read that because read
ollie recommended it it's a great book
yeah yeah I the number of people I meet
that are like they've read it and anyway
the takeaway is that things happen over
and over again or at least certain
patterns emerge and I guess what I'm
saying is if you look back at history
you can learn a lot from reading
people's history whether it's a
biography or a history of a specific
segment of companies so for instance I
think if you want to study the
acquisitions of companies and where
those founders have gone and what
they've done and more importantly what
do most founders do next after selling a
company and taking some months off how
many take one month off how many take a
year how many take five years how many
never emerge again right like but how
what are the differences between those
who that decide to do something and
those that don't
so even in my own exploration of what's
next in my life I find myself not
reading necessarily biographies but I do
read accounts of you know entrepreneurs
that have launched big things and none
you know new things in the future and
those who haven't and I start asking
myself like what are the patterns that
emerge so no I don't read biographies
yet but I want to and in history I think
more generally is a super interesting
topic there's some excellent biographies
out there I I think you might enjoy
Genghis Khan and the making of the
modern world
ok excellent excellent book for a lot of
reasons I'm trying to think of the ones
that have been recommended to me yeah
I'll have to get back to you on that
David McCullough has a lot of really
good biographies and the Wright brothers
and so on
was actually given to me by very very
successful consumer packaged goods
entrepreneur here in Austin which turns
out to be sort of ground zero or the
epicenter of a lot of CPG stuff so cool
yeah and this is an interesting how many
people have so many similar patterns in
their lives and I think there's this
like great equalizer when you realize
what you are doing or going through or
whatever well it might be super unique
to you and you're 35 or 41 years it
actually turns out like it happens over
and over again to people on their lives
not everyone but like it's occurred in
the past and you have a lot to learn
from it that's basically my point and
that that I think it's a hundred twenty
page book lessons of history is a
fantastic place to start I expected it I
actually downloaded it as a Kindle book
and let it sit there for months because
I expected it to be very dry and it's
beautifully written book it's very
impressed and then if if you like that
as a taste test and then you can go into
there what is it like 10 or 20 volume
and summary of their volumes right
that's right yeah it's like the cliff
notes the cliff yes I'd like to ask you
this is one of the questions that I'd
been hoping to ask
ever since we book the podcast and that
is about advice that you give to
entrepreneurs that very few actually
take and I'll explain just by way of
example I'm asked all the time how how
various folks should launch books where
people come to me asking how should I
launch a book how should I write a book
how should I get a book published and I
might tell them for instance don't try
to write for the entire world if your
goal is to the New York Times bestseller
list write for like 10 to 20,000 people
per week in other words you really only
need to get the flywheel spinning
because people use the bestseller list
as a shopping list to to write a book
that at least 20,000 people will love
but they end up writing something too
general they end up writing something
too general
and I tell them to give themselves a ton
of buffer before the book is published
and to write it in such a way that for
instance it can be read module early and
then they don't do that and they wonder
why they can't run excerpts and it's
it's it's been incredible to me how you
know I put together a blog post just
like how to write a best-selling book
this year where I lay out the exact
playlist or not playlist rather but
playbook and nonetheless it's like one
out of a hundred who actually implement
even a portion of the steps are there
any particular bits of advice or
recommendations that you give to on
Ferrer's that you're surprised aren't
taken more seriously or actually
followed yeah number one advice I always
give is to solve a problem so many
people when they found a company found a
company just to found a company or
they're like I've got an idea
ideas are not company's ideas are not
products like you're like well I'm gonna
combine this thing with this trend and
we're gonna do this it's a cool idea and
you know usually the warning signs are
that includes some element of a current
fad like AI or something not that AI is
a fad but like you know it's a wave
that's happening right now that I think
it's easy to make your company sound
more interesting if you're just like and
it uses AI or like crypto or like there
are always warning signs that I see with
the pitches that I that I hear from
people when they include those words and
it's not backed up by a clear problem
that you're solving for the person on
the other side or the company on the
other side the counterparty right so I
always say make sure you're actually
solving a problem now there are
different ways that can be wrong
it could be solved already really well
in which case you're not solving a
problem the idea might be great but
you're not solving a problem it can be a
really neat idea with not a lot of
people that need that problem to be
solved in which case it's not really a
problem for the world
right maybe we could broaden this by
saying solve a problem for the world or
it just misunderstands what people need
or it doesn't even take into account
what people need you're just like ah it
sounds really cool I'm gonna do this
this and it's a hot market so I'm gonna
figure it out and the number of times
I've seen entrepreneurs go that
direction because it feels good to be
part of the trend it feels good to say
you have a cool idea
without asking yourself does this
actually solve someone's problem like if
I go talk to people does this literally
like relieve people that this now exists
the number of times I've seen people
ignore this advice that's countless
what's crazy to me is I feel like it's
our secret sauce at instrum and I'm like
this is great like we could just keep
doing this right like every product we
work on hopefully is solving someone's
problem and I feel like I'm giving this
advice away for free but no one's taking
it that's that's it's also true for
nonfiction books right yeah the number
of books you pick up and it's like I
bought the book because I have the
problem you don't have to spend eighty
percent of the book describing the
problem you got it yeah what are other
common mistakes that you observe among
entrepreneurs or creators so we could
make it make it broader it doesn't have
to be broader but people who are trying
to do their own thing entrepreneurs are
otherwise what are some common mistakes
you see and it could be it could be
within the venture-backed startup world
but it could also be broader than that I
think going it alone is often a mistake
and that doesn't mean you have to have a
co-founder but not having a team is a
mistake I see a bunch people feeling
like oh I'm just gonna do this by myself
I'm just gonna there's an incredible
power and having people around you even
individuals who are like maybe the face
their company I have an incredible team
around them and I think trying to do it
all yourself is like not only a recipe
for getting it wrong but also a recipe
for not being able to get back up I mean
how do you get up when you get punched
down well sometimes having someone else
in the room with you to be like yeah
let's get up and get them you know yeah
it helps I think that's a mistake I see
a lot
you know the crazy thing is that having
gone through it and making mistakes
yourself it's not clear to me that like
those are all mistakes in every other
situation so I'm trying to be careful in
over prescribing my situation because
there are counter examples is water
that's the really important point
actually that I think is worth
underscoring for folks and that is for
for nearly every rule that someone might
prescribe there's probably a counter
example you know the say leader of which
would prescribe the exact opposite yeah
right and so it's it's I suppose in part
finding the rules that are compatible
also with what you hold to be the core
values or philosophies that guide you
like being passionate about the product
or the service with the company because
that has some real practical
implications if you're not passionate
are you in fact going to be able to
summon the endurance like you said to
sort of walk through or around or climb
over the various walls are gonna pop up
probably not right so then you can find
the examples that sort of suit your
personality and the set of values that
you've set out for giving company what
this is this is a metaphor question but
if you could in just a few more
questions and then we'll yeah we'll wrap
up if you could put a message quote a
word a question anything non-commercial
on a billboard and really what I'm
asking is to get a message to billions
of people which it's crazy to think that
you you can't actually do that now and
so these platforms like like Instagram
but to get a message simultaneously to
billions of people could be an image
what what might you put on that
billboard I don't know if it sounds
cheesy but the advice that I got that
has driven me the entire way is follow
your passion like I cared so deeply
about social media and so deeply about
photography and there are so many people
that were like
social media is crowded photography is
lame you don't mean that like the only
way to get through those is by loving
the thing are the mission that you're on
and well again it sounds kind of cheesy
maybe we could wordsmith this follow
your passion thing but like the number
of people that don't follow their
passion because people talk them out of
it and I think that's a crime
yeah right but of course you can't
follow your passion and not expect
consequences like listen if your passion
is to go fly-fishing and you want to do
that all the time that's great but you
often know okay like can I pay my bills
right like can I there are there are
constraints but if you've thought
through it and you love it there should
be no one standing in your way
yeah and like the number of people that
tried to stand in our way like they
still like listen even long into
Instagram there were people you know
predicting our demise and so I don't
know like at a certain point it's not
like ignore the haters that could be the
other billboard by the way um it's it's
like you got to follow your passion as
long as you've thought through it you've
done the math you think about it like go
for it and don't let people stand in
your way
you know like it's just so sad when
people don't do that and life is short
like you said I mean our lives are so
short relative to sort of the span of
human history and I think that's another
benefit of reading history as it puts
that in perspective like these lives are
sort of the the flicker of I thinking of
all raava competent like the flicker of
a Firefly in the scope of history it's
really short really tiny and I had this
uh this one coach who said to me he's
like often people wake up when they have
someone close to them that dies or or
they come down with some really serious
illness and they realize all the little
things they were spending all this time
worried about don't matter compared to
these like grave big things in life
and it's important to keep that
perspective so I'm not trying to get all
like serious here but like I think it's
really important to keep things in
perspective and I think that I don't
know like I guess it's another word for
maturity right but um the faster you can
get there the faster you realize a lot
of what you think matters doesn't matter
and the things that you're not thinking
about matter a lot more than you're
giving them credit for yeah which is why
you should follow your passion and love
what you do every day don't get me wrong
by the way I want to clarify a lot of
people are like you should love what you
do and I agree but I think it's more you
should love what you're shooting for
yeah because work is hard yeah it can be
miserable at times I mean nothing great
in this world ever came easy like if you
want to be an amazing guitarist you're
not gonna get there easily trained
really hard get shot down a bunch right
like they're all like it's a universal
law in the world that great things come
with a lot of work yeah and what you
have to do is I think love the thing
you're shooting for rather than the
everyday of the thing but I think a lot
of people are like I should love every
day it's like no no every day can be
there are a lot of hard days ahead the
thing that gets you through those days
is loving the outcome you're shooting
for and being excited to get there
someday
well Kevin I'm excited to see what you
had next thank you I'll see if after
you've done your pattern recognition on
this down meta-analysis of founders who
do various things of various points I'll
be curious to see where you end up but
give any closing remarks anything you'd
like to ask people to do any thing at
all that you'd like to say before we
wrap up no pressure right you don't you
don't have to tell your friends about
this podcast I like that recommendation
awesome thanks for having me this was a
lot of fun yeah good to see you again
and to everybody listening for links to
everything that came up the
and all sorts of other things the names
of people and so on we will provide
links to all of that in the show notes
as always at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast you can just search kevin or
system and it will pop right up and
until next time thank you for listening
you